[Music]
hello friends thank you guys so much for
joining us this is daily Danni live I'm
Denny I'm not gonna lie I have not
washed my hair yet I'm like running on
just a couple hours of sleep but
thankfully I brought in some lovely
reinforcements to recap the Grammy
Awards we've got Katy Kraus hey miss
Sophia Lacey oh what a night the Grammy
Awards are one of my favorites for sure
music's biggest night we're gonna break
down the things you guys didn't see on
TV or maybe miss but of course we got to
start with the fashion on the red carpet
because the fashion at the Grammys is
next-level it's over-the-top 100 percent
and nobody makes an entrance like a Lady
Gaga she showed up you guys in Armani
Prive and at first glance it looks like
a dress but no it is a lace black
bodysuit with a massive skirt over it
and look at the size of that train
reportedly it took three people to carry
that thing down the red carpet I am NOT
and look at the back of this dress you
guys that's how huge the train is and
her hair like that weave is just really
amazing and fun fact once she got inside
she actually took off this skirt for
part of the night probably because it
was a little bit too hard to out move
around it I love it because last year at
the Grammys she should've been like for
her Metallica performance on tea and
studded this was very like glam for the
Grammys boss were very Gaga I loved it
what do you guys think of course fashion
is very subjective we want to know what
you guys think so let us know in the
comment section below tell us who your
favorites were hopefully we'll get to
them right here in this iPad but now
what I really love about the Grammys is
that it's a place where people can be
super bold with their fashion and take
risks that you wouldn't see at any other
award show another look that I loved was
pink
she was also rocking Armani Prive
looking just incredible in this
multicolored feather number she posted
about on Instagram and said that she
wore it because she's fun and I have to
agree and what I love about Pink's sense
of style is that she can walk she can
rock menswear she can rock super girly
glam chic she can rock feathers a crazy
look and she always looks incredible and
then she did the
opposite on stage for her performance
she wore just a plain white t-shirt and
jeans barefoot just slayed the stage so
I love you baby that's what makes her
one of the more exciting people to see
on a red carpet because you don't know
where she's gonna step right like you're
right when at the VMAs when she rocked
that suit with the rest of her family
I'm like yes like that Marlene Dietrich
look you know but then at the Grammys
total glam and amazing I love now she
did the opposite during her performance
um you guys will notice that Gaga and
pink are both wearing white roses
they're among the many stars wearing
white roses on the red carpet in
solidarity with victims of sexual
harassment and in fact we talked to
Kelly Clarkson on the red carpet about
the significance of the Rose like I
remember years ago when that whole thing
came out and and you know I think it is
it is something that happens not only in
the music industry or with actors like
whatever film industry whatever it is it
happens everywhere like with my friends
who have normal jobs like and I think
that's the that's the whole reason you
know it's like we're trying to beat a
dead horse it's it you're trying to
challenge people and keep it relevant
and in constant and thought of like
making sure that you're being respectful
human and your work environment and and
also making sure that we're teaching our
children to do better than we have done
you know you better preach French guys
love her everything she says but
obviously the times that movement has
been very prevalent throughout award
season but we haven't seen so much
talked about in the music industry so it
was kind of amazing to see that that
message of solidarity and the unity
really in and and she's right I remember
these conversations really started with
Kesha you know and of course it was her
first appearance at the Grammys and her
emotional performance had a lot to do
with what she's been going through it
was a huge moment and what I kind of
liked about the white roses too was that
they were all different I know some
people have criticized this because they
felt like there wasn't a uniform look to
it some people wore real flowers some
people wore pins some people held roses
not everybody had the exact same thing
on their outfit I kind of liked that I
liked that too and it's very fitting for
music your artistry is so different
depending on the person and I think to
let everyone choose was special Kelly
even said in that interview at with et
that the White Rose thing came after she
figured out what she was gonna wear so
cause I'll just hold a you know and so
that's where she did I mean you can't
blame it's the Grammys yeah you know all
right moving on guys
scissor fizzling is that look amazing in
Versace as part of the spring 2017 Oh
fall I want to say fall 2017 collection
she almost looks a cereal in this silver
sparkly sequined gown they're slits in
all the right places there's tulle bell
sleeves would you guys make of it Best
Dressed I mean honest yes when you when
you are a Best New Artist nominee when
you've had a breakthrough year like
scissor has yeah you gotta show up to
the Grammys to stun them and that's
exactly what she did and you know we
actually talked her on the carpet to is
she was just as excited as we are about
her life she was glowing watch her talk
about in gush about this custom Versace
number thank you for seeing something in
me just custom-fit this dress I don't
even know how I got the other wing but
such a good singer but she's favorite
thing about see we know you grew the
scale of scissors look so much I mean so
cute Shepley know what Donna tell us on
her right exactly yeah she put her mom
and grandma on the red carpet I mean
what a moment for her she didn't take
home Best New Artist but certainly
best-dressed yes now another glittering
goddess glowing goddess on the red
carpet was Chrissy Teigen showing off
her baby bump in full force wearing is
silvery Ioannina Kutcher or make sure
I'm saying that right um just look so
happy
I love that she said on Twitter that she
likes being pregnant better than you
know any other time in her life and you
can tell she's really enjoying it I also
loved that she posted on Instagram that
she and John were home by 10:30 last
night they were dancing all night so he
feels like they danced themselves out
yeah I mean it's rimfire you gotta call
it yeah I didn't like going to this
thing sober
yeah yeah and I don't blame her John and
Chrissy of course always bringing in a
couple's goals
yeah and carpet another couple bringing
the goals in my opinion Maren Morris and
Ryan heard I thought was so so so cute
together Ryan in a bonobos tux and Maren
and Julien Macdonald and Lorraine
Schwartz Jules Maren really showing off
some skin here working in all the right
places
yes it's working for I mean she's got
such a cute little bod - she always
looks so good and they're actually
getting married in two months so maybe
she's sweating for the wedding told us
that when he proposed she was in her
sweats and glasses and then to see her
all glammed up here it's just again the
Grammys you get to bring that glitz and
glamour again Oh both Maren and Chrissy
rocked the shimmer Chrissy by the way
also revealed on Instagram it because
she was wrong she was showing out for
her her gown but she's having a baby boy
they're having a boy just so exciting
Leopold Marin and Chrissy really turned
it out with those looks
but God give it up to John and Ryan -
for the dudes like those suits were a
little bit I want to start with from the
from the ground up because Thomas Rhett
brought some Gucci loafers that were so
on point um you guys he actually opted
for no tie but it's all about the shoe
look at the shoe right there bird
they're free and let me remind you like
this is a country star and this guy's
rocking a loafer like I don't need socks
smart that's exactly right and like I
mentioned it was kind of funny that he
opted for NotI open his shirt but
everybody had that lion on the collar to
do another fun detail you know relaxed
but it was all about the detail so I had
to give him a shout-out also it was a
night of turtlenecks for the guys at the
Grammys jay-z among them you know Jay Z
and Beyonce have been hitting all the
pre-grammy parties that's jay-z and
Diddy right there and uh they've been
looking so stylish and he saved this
turtleneck for the Grammys as did Diddy
with this coat over Neath over it I
of this leg it's look cheap but relaxed
it's very suave yes absolutely
their swag down I loved it also another
thing tonight for the guys was color
Sam Smith stepped out in a really
interesting green - Rudy 1881 suit can
we talk about the Christmas colors
that's fair I don't love it you know he
has a you know his style choices have
been very interesting lately yeah you
usually goes for the laid back a little
more casual look you can tell with the
with the shirt with the the kunuk shirt
I did love the double-breasted green
suit though very white like button-up or
something with it I could see your point
well I think if you're gonna experiment
the Grammys are a great place to do that
and it is kind of fun you have the Navy
and the maroon and then you had the
green yes I get what you're saying but I
think it's fun yeah I'll never fall
someone for trying something I think
that's a great place to do it
I didn't love it but you know I'm sure
plenty of other people did know listen
he definitely loved and he's having such
a good time in it in fact he changed for
the performance changed back into it for
the after parties you guys take a look
at this shot of Sam Spade getting down
with that boyfriend Brandon at Mark
Ronson's after-party at the Grammys I
mean this boy's getting his life guys
fYI Danny's been very excited about this
photo already you know living their best
life
Zayn Malik he showed up in this yeah
paint Richard James suit tailored so
perfectly is my best dressed yes good
listen someone in the office told me
today that we're all gonna chip in and
try and find me that suit thank you
thank you so good but came over here say
she loved
Marin's dress loving all the sparkle on
the carpet Arnaldo love and Lana's look
says she looked amazing
gucci goddess last night - Louis
cream-colored gown
halo headpiece you know who else was a
goddess we got to talk about Lord guy
Lauren I think was my best dressed
female of the night she showed up in
Valon
you know this fiery red dress look at
that it has the spaghetti straps and
then it's almost like cascading feathers
all the way down but what I also loved
is the message that she pinned to the
back of the dress she shared it on
Instagram and it was her way to sort of
show her support for the me to movement
and in a way she was a little bit
ostracized by ostracized
I can speak today hi the Grammys she was
the only Best Album nominee not to be
offered a solo performance right so I
think this was her way of speaking out
it was a poem by Jenny Holzer and props
to Lorde she was still a good sport
throughout the night I was gonna say
that explains why she was drinking yeah
there she is
see that's classy but she was still
clapping for everyone there's photos of
her hanging out with Miley Cyrus and
meeting jay-z can I just see the best of
it if I was nominated in the Grammy
audience and honestly not performing I
would bring a flask Rihanna did it last
year
Lorde hit this year she coordinated with
her Elvis you know she was Jewish
because this is a long night I'm not
performing so she did not walk the red
carpet no at all she did not um so yeah
if you guys were wondering why she
didn't perform as Katy explained you
know a source told et that she was asked
to actually perform as part of the Tom
Petty tribute but politely declined and
she was not offered a solo performance
it just American Girl by the way which
is very bizarre for New Zealand yeah so
yeah um I would have loved to see Lauren
perform last night and money for
supercut to be a single I don't think
that that would have been a fun moment
props what a jazz things up a little bit
props are because melodrama was such a
good album she only scored one
nomination but it was for the big one
yeah at least she was recognized in that
way and to be the only female in that
category props you Lord yes I'm glad she
showed up there were so many harmonies
that didn't even show up
props to Lord for showing up having a
good time being good sport using her
platform to send a message perhaps to
you Lord someone else who was a Missy
and notably missing from the Grammys was
Bieber you have mama yeah so Bieber was
not part of the Dust Osito performance
even though it was up for record of the
they're all that good stuff Louie Fonzie
actually did tell us ahead of time that
Bieber would not be a part of it so he
did have fair warning so where was
Bieber he was in Santa Monica yeah so no
real word why he declined cuz Louie
Fonzie also told us that yes he did ask
Bieber of course to be a part of the
performance it was such a huge moment
but he just wasn't feeling it I guess
take a look at what Louie told us that
rehearsals yeah of course of course of
course we extended the invitation he's
part of the nomination you know and he
helped the song grow even more you know
and and I'm so proud of the job that he
did I'm so proud that he decided to sing
you know most of the song in Spanish the
chorus in Spanish so we're very grateful
he's a good friend he's a good guy so
I'm you know hopefully we'll be able to
to celebrate together listen Louis if
you ever need a stand-in under God visa
leave I see you Luis FONSI and I do have
the same hairstyle
speaking of Bruno of course he was the
big winner of the night collecting six
Grammy Awards including record album and
song of the year it was a huge night for
Bruno you know it was a huge night for
him not such a good night for jay-z who
was shut out completely he was shocked
by that most nominated eight nominations
we went home with zero Grammys which
might explain why when Bruno walked up
to accept album of the year we spotted
Beyonce standing but not clapping we
have a quick little clip of that right
there
all right so here's Bruno accepting
album of the year and in the back that
shadow you see is Beyonce the shadow
back there's beyonce her husband just
lost album of beer I'm sure she was just
tired or something you know or like you
don't want to ruin her manager but she
was could you imagine being blue ivy
though by the way who was also in the
audience
see your parents lose albums a year
back-to-back years I would Ryan I would
write tantrum and as we learned last
night Blue Ivy's running the show you
guys if you missed this watch Blue Ivy
tell her dad jay-z and mother Beyonce to
simmer down I'm trying to listen quiet
mom get stop mom I mean we know who runs
the the Carter household at a tea party
you might have missed it during the
telecast but she was trying to enjoy the
show and during that moment yes Camila
Cabello was up on stage speaking it
wasn't the musical performance or
anything but Balu just wanted to hear
Camille okay
which I love also fun fact you guys
Beyonce was wearing 6.8 million dollars
worth of Lorraine Schwartz and jewelry
last night a small amount I mean of her
earrings alone I think had 70 carats
worth of diamonds in there her neck must
be hurting this morning because between
the Hat the the earrings on yeah it's a
lot yeah that's a lot by the way her
dress in her hat it's all Nicholas
Gibran and it was her paying tribute to
the Black Panthers sixties movement
movement which I love yeah moving on
though there was another big moment for
Blue Ivy she got to hang with Alicia
Keys a photo of Alicia look at blue just
showing off her little purse and Alicia
knows what's up she's got a listen huh
say what's up to blue I love Alicia by
the way she's so awesome and I think it
was so cute I would love to be a fly on
the wall and know what they were talking
about it was a big night for celebrity
kids actually right yes it was Pink's
daughter Willow actually got to meet her
idol Rihanna backstage is so cute how
cute is this pink actually posted on
Instagram about how both she and Willow
worship RiRi you know as one does and I
guess this was a huge huge moment for
willow so very exciting for her I would
have to imagine that both pink and
Beyonce get the cool mom cards
absolutely yes I'm glad they're bringing
blue to this stuff yeah you know when
are the twins gonna show all right we're
wrapping up here guys but quickly Eric
you said oh my god Lady Gaga's Galland
the best dress of the night it's amazing
Dominic's Dominique a love Neos blazer
he rocked like a really yellow
mustard-yellow blazer and it definitely
stood out that's gonna be with me oh I
am gonna be with me okay Wednesday we're
gonna be live to make sure you guys tune
in to laugh but ya know wouldn't I
freaking love the Grammys highlight to
the night oh I really loved Cash's
performance with all the women I mean
you a Cyndi Lauper you Camilla Kibeho up
there just truly an empowering
performance and I got chills I had some
chills watching that I had chills I had
some tears Kesha was definitely a
highlight for me on the other end of it
though it was such a heavy night I
really love seeing Rihanna perform and
just I just genuinely like sticking out
her tongue making faces having a great
time best time yeah so that was the fun
moment for me that I really want an
attorney being brunei was good for your
speaking you cannot deny we have plenty
more coverage over IE t online.com you
guys from all the performances most
talked about moments things you didn't
see on TV so head over there right now
ET online and of course tonight on
Entertainment Tonight we're taking you
to the Grammy after-party so check your
local listings
a lot of Grammy love today from ET and a
lot of love for me thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed
like and share this video and I'll be
back tomorrow with another daily Denny
thank you guys for joining me
[Music]
you